it's been so difficult you know hearing
patients complaining about the care
they're receiving I met cafelatz and
Linda on December the 15th the first day
of the nurses strike a month later and
nothing has changed there is no end in
sight I still feel detected about the
way things are going the government is
not listening it's such a disrespect to
the whole profession the reason why
we're mostly going on strike and we can
talk to people is their concern for the
quality of care that they're able to
provide for the patients and that hasn't
changed either
on Monday ambulance workers from the
unite Unison and GMB unions are striking
in the escalating dispute over Peyton
Staffing
and the biggest walkouts in the health
services history is also looming nurses
and ambulance staff are both set to
strike on February the 6th taking
industrial action on the same day for
the first time ever
[Applause]
NHS leaders are looking at contingency
plans but there are fear Services could
grind to a halt the strikes have hit the
Health Service and its patients hard the
latest data shows over 5 000 procedures
and over 20 000 appointments have had to
be postponed and rescheduled due to
Industrial action and the longer the
strikes drag on well more patients will
be affected union leaders insist they
want to negotiate but think the
government isn't interested in doing a
deal to end their strike action Rishi
sunak I have to say is missing in action
I don't know where he is and I have to
say we are concluding now that there
must be a much more Sinister reason for
this because this level of self-harm is
unprecedented
the government says it's committed to
Bringing Down the seven million strong
waiting list but Health analysts sworn
that will not be possible unless this
dispute is settled soon unless he
strikes a result you're not going to see
those waiting this cleared and you're
going to see a deterioration in patient
access to services I don't see a sort of
digging in playing the long game
strategy working here I think the
government is going to have to look at
what its options are and look at what a
settlement might be the government has
described the latest strike action as
hugely disappointing and it insists a
double-digit pay rise for nurses is
simply not affordable
and Linda are worried about their
patience but also about paying their
heating bills they don't want a long
bitter dispute let's say the government
has given them little choice
oh she's Josh